hey everybody and welcome to an
energetic wild ride with st we've got
Sebastian Bach and let me tell you this
guy is a riot I mean he just comes into
the van and he's on fire and he's more
fun and more candid about just a
checkered sleazy past then you could ask
an 80s hair metal Legend to to be I mean
it doesn't get more fun than this so
strap on your seat bels and let's get to
it woo we're here nice how you doing
good can my kids meet you dude after
they're all they're so excited yeah you
bet dude all right um so before uh just
before we start let me just get a sense
of anything that you want to
avoid
well I mean how about the
80s avoid
that I mean I'm not always about I just
joking I mean there's a couple of really
horrible things I did so that I don't
like talking about all right but you
know I mean I mean I think I think we'll
uh you
know we'll whatever it is what it is it
is what it is man all right well dude
like I say we just keep that cuz that
was really funny
ladies and Gentlemen people of the
Universe I bring to you Sebastian B hi
hello yeah dude I'll tell you everybody
who I have mentioned in passing that
we're going to meet up with you has like
their head has exploded they're so
excited about it my lady can't even
believe it like yeah my girl was stoked
too yeah everybody's super super stoked
well the very first thing I want to say
the Steve this first time I've ever
meeting you but it's
not because guess what what you always
tell the
story about and I just heard it on the
Eddie Trunk show the other day on your
interview how you called Scott McGee in
Toronto and got a hold of him at the
hotel and he got you backstage at mle
crew yeah I was there too backstage at
that show and I have
pictures backstage with Nikki and I was
there too so it all matches up the same
outfits and everything huh I'm just
saying you were you're a little younger
than me yeah but not much yeah and you
were at that gig and I was at that gig I
mean my story for that gig is a little
different though because my
band was called V5 we had the five
coolest hair DS in Toronto
yeah this and our logo I steamed off the
V5 shampoo bottle and that was our logo
V5 yeah we only did two shows it wasn't
a big bad with but one of the shows
Nikki and Tommy came it was the night
before that gig and Nikki and Tommy came
to our gig at Rock and Roll Heaven
downtown across from Harvey's on
blure right at near the Corner young
employ he used to walk down them stairs
and there was this club there I don't
know if you were old enough to get in no
no no I was 13 on that day yeah okay so
so Nikki and Tommy came and everybody
goes to me hey
man Nikki and Tommy are here and they're
looking for the best blow in to and I'm
like
hello I'm the singer of the band for SES
and they're like right this way singer
of band I guess who had the best
blow in
to that was me man and they were my best
buddies that night tomby and Nikki we
were [__] do
somea sniffle snacks some some beer
sodas and uh and they're like you're
coming backstage tomorrow I go yeah I am
got believe it I was like the best did
you bring blow backstage the next night
yes I did and I brought black hash and I
was smoking it in the backstage room and
Fred Saunders said hey hey please don't
don't smoke Ash backstage and I was like
[__] it's Molly Crew like dude how about
that show how about that show when that
was the 80s by the way I have to say for
all these people listening the uh the
this was the girls girls girls tour 87
of 1987 and this was the tour when Tommy
Lee's drum set came up over the crowd
and then rotated upside down I have a
funny story about that too and at the
beginning of that drum solo there was
like all right you know Vince Vince says
you want to have a drink with the crew
Tonto yes and uh so then like Nikki 6
like brings a bottle of Jack Daniels
he's like all right we're gonna and
Nikki like pours like sprays the crowd
with the with the Jack Daniels so that
they can like tell it's real whiskey
they're not like you know it's it's not
fake and then so now it's like cheers to
the crowd we're going to have a drink
and Nikki like just puts the bottle
upside down just chugging and on each
chug Tommy Lee
like like timing the chugs with like
drum bead boom boom they're putting down
a fifth putting just chugging whiskey
and that's how and that's how the drum
solo
started you know and that like what an
epic way to start a drum solo well I
have a couple of comments to that is the
the tour before two tours before because
there was theater of pain and I went to
that I went to in Toronto and then me
and my buddies got in our car and drove
to Ottawa and watched it again um and
but the tour before that the first time
Molly Crew played Toronto was Shout at
the Devil so they would have been
opening for aie no except was opening
for them they were headlining at the
little tiny CN grand stand Arena which
was like 4,000 Cedar so we were so
freaked out that mly crew is headlining
in Toronto and the shadow of the devil
to so we got a bunch of mushrooms and
went and stayed overnight in the line
like we got there at like 6:00 p.m.
and I was like 14 nice and doing shms
okay now this is in Nikki's
book which one I mean what is it like
book four now or something yeah well so
this was in the book we woke up okay and
we didn't really sleep obviously right
we thought it was a great idea and
[__] we're all whacked out and up on
shrooms and [__] and we're right at the
very very front in fact me and my
buddies are smushed up against like the
glass like this like like this
like and all these croutons are behind
us pushing and this guy this crazy guy
next to me with no shirt on and [__] and
he was all drunk and everything and he
goes this [__] he goes we're not stay in
here and he turns around and he this is
all true he kicks the glass out of the
the front of the CN grand stand doors
and I go and we bend down and the whole
crowd runs in wow and there was like a
thousand kids and we rush the stage I
remember this like yesterday and the
crews on the stage and they back up they
go whoa whoa and we get right to the
front we go crew crew crew creww and it
was like 2 p.m. and they're trying to
set up Sound Check Yes and Nikki
remembers his they had to pay he goes
that was you I go well there was a guy
next to me but I was the first one in
and they had to pay for all the new
doors and [__] cops came yes the cops
came in and said get the out of here and
we were all scared we're going to get
arrested and that was fun time Jesus wow
shout of the devil yeah but that was
good that was a different time like if
any of my kids are watching this like I
don't I mean dude what a dude the 80s
man I and then wait there's another
sorry there's another story when you
talk
about Tommy's Drum Kit revolving yeah
yeah um we my we opened every show on
the do Feelgood tour okay with Skid Row
in '89 in Europe the whole tour uhhuh
and I had a
little thinging with uh Christina
Applegate um oh wow I don't know if you
know her story when she goes I left Brad
Pit one night for some guy and I'm not
going to even say who was
hello that would be me that was her with
the mared children days that was the MTV
Awards that night and she came with Brad
Pit and left with me mother
druger wow true story so I fly her to
Paris to see me play with mle grw and
her mom comes and her aunt comes and we
go to the Eiffel Tower we go to dinner
and all this stuff so at the mle Cruz
show going up and standing right side
stage and Nikki goes hey he's standing
up on the top thing and I'm like hey man
because I was like I didn't want to be
like you know the guying the [__] up on
the stage yeah so so I go we better move
you know like so we walk across and
Tommy tomy's Trump goes up and starts
turning and then it stops and he's stuck
and I thought I [__] unplugged his
drum kit no I go holy we got to get the
out of here because we I was walking
right there and then it stopped and he's
like hanging upside down in France and I
go oh my God I unplugged his drums and
the show's wrecked and I it was AED up
night he was like hanging upside down
cuz he wanted a key bump he was just
waiting for you to V but I thought I
kicked out the cord you know and he's
upside down and I was like f must have
did Tommy tell us about how uh his his
drum techs would like come
in oh just shovel it into his nose yeah
that was uh wasn't it like they were
like I used to do that Some Guns and
Roses guys they did like used to like
was like bottle caps full oh my God
bottle cap yeah yeah were you there the
night that Guns and Roses try to
outdrink mly
crew there's a shocker Scott Randolph
wants to talk about Rockstar drinking
well I want to talk about rock stars
eating the rock stars I'm talking about
are my cats do you have cats are your
cats eating kibble because I'm telling
you that's the equivalent of gas station
food I've come to realize man that my
pets deserve to eat better than crappy
kibble first I started feeding fresh
human grade food to my dogs then I found
out about this company called Smalls
they make fresh real properly healthy
food for cats and the cats are a lot
happier and a lot healthier because of
it and man they this company is so
fantastic they've got an offer for you
that is not only risk-free but it's
50% off and free shipping and if your
cats don't love this fresh very real
food that they make
then send it back and get your money
back it's risk-free and uh man I'm
telling you dude my cats I care about
them I love them I love all my animals
and I want them to have the best lives
possible and it's all about their
nutrition so Smalls is the way to go if
you want to try this you go to Smalls s
m a l
ls.com steo and use the promo code steo
you're going to get 50% off your first
order plus free shipping and it's
totally risk-free because if your cat
doesn't absolutely love it then send it
back get your money back I mean dude it
doesn't get any better than that and if
you love your cats then do this for them
man they deserve it my cats do so one
more time go to
small.com steo and use the promo code
steo to get 50% off your first order
plus free shipping now let's get back to
it and they ended up making Tommy Lee
was saying that uh who who passed out uh
think Steve Adler I think no no no uh
maybe slash passed out and they put
their balls on his forehead and they
made that as the backstage VIP pass for
the show the next night you remember him
saying that on the on the Tommy Lee
episode oh that that's fantastic I just
remember Tommy taught me so much needo
stuff like like in Canada where we come
from when I was a kid we all smoke black
hash and it was like kind of an involved
process you would heat up the hash and
then mix it with the tobacco and then
you know get a nice blend we did this
all day and then smoke that [__] but
when I met Tommy Lee he goes he got
anything to smoke I go yeah I got some
black hat she goes give me that and it's
just like a little Cube and he just
takes it and it in his fingers with the
match she
goes well what the
[__] not it's not rolling it or blend he
just give me that [__] [__] and
that's that's really cutting to the
chase I don't think he's going for Taste
no no he's just trying to get high bro
we asked U we asked Tommy how they
smuggle drugs into different like
countries oh yeah what was your favorite
tactic well I have a funny little story
we we opened for Molly Crew in Russia
the first Russian metal sh oh this is
the one where everybody was on the
airplane and they were sober yeah were
they really sober
no I can say that now it's 40 years ago
yeah right they are but I said that then
and Tommy I was backstage in Russia and
he's walking towards me he go she
[__] say he grabs me he goes did you
say some [__] and I
go and and I go
if I was bragging about drinking with
mly crew I was such a fan like who how
can you not say I was partying with the
crew I mean sorry they uh would have a
the world believe that they recorded
doctor Feelgood all completely sober and
for me as a kid and what made me love
mle crew like I had to boycut that
album well I can tell you you can listen
to it yeah so so what was what was the
story behind I was in I was in Russia I
was in
Russia I as yeah I asked the road crew
the Russian road crew you guys got any
black hash man and this one Russian dude
goes oh comrade yes you wait right there
and he goes and gets me a bunch of hash
and and I'm telling doc on the way home
go yeah doc I had some leftover so
leaving Russia I have these pointy White
boots and I I put them right in the toe
man and I walk through the airport like
that and and I go and and uh you know
and Doc looks at me goes oh they'll
never think of that like yeah the first
place they're going to check whoa I go
yeah I put it in my shoe and I was
walking around goes
whoa it's the first thing that's the
next level smuggling right there wow
like Oh They'll Never think of that like
I go wow maybe I shouldn't have did that
you would know by the
way what other uh that's what the whole
concert was about what other places
would you smuggle drugs
into or would you get them there well
let's let's clarify this right I don't
do the only thing I like still is
smoking weed and that's legal everywhere
I don't mess with nothing else but in
the 80s it was like back then we we did
Coke we didn't know we honest to God
didn't know it was bad I'll tell you
when I knew it was bad in like the year
91 or something you can Google this when
did Len Bias die maybe that was a the
basketball player and that was not that
was from smok and crack right 86 I can't
cardiac Ry okay then what I just said is
[__] I like that was the day and I
was definitely doing it after that
day I mean I was like what I I turn a
new you might definitely not an no but I
remember saying what do you mean he died
at 37 from Doom blow and they go and
then people are explain to me well you
could if you could if you do a line and
it hits your heart like the wrong way
you can have a heart attack and die and
I go I I don't like it that much you
know and I really really hate the
feeling like when you run out and you're
trying to go to sleep and there's none
left and you're calling people and it's
11:00 a.m. and crying in the shower and
like look up I look up I go Lord Jesus
if you just let me go to [__] sleep
I'll never [__] do this again dude I
remember sure and then you go to sleep
and you do it again I remember at the
time where like when there was like the
Moto Motorola Razor cell phone like I I
was in such this hellish hellish
condition that Sebastian's explaining
and like I'm calling the drug dealer to
get more drugs cuz I want them so bad
but I'm so worn out like that I'm going
to crash and so I'm laying down on the
floor and literally using my like like
my Motorola Razor as a
pillow so that if it rings it'll wake me
up and so I can do more drugs but like
but if if not then I'm just going to
fall asleep I remember I remember when
Metallica and Guns and Roses played
giant stadium in Jersey I went to hatan
to pick up the lead singer Hanley rocks
Mike Monroe and and we had a ton of coke
and we brought it there and I was all
weirded out this is what like near the
end of the days when it felt good and so
we're coming back to Manhattan the sun's
coming up and I dropped the [__] on the
floor right we only have a tiny bit left
and it's a carpeted limo and we're on
our hands and knees going through the
carpet looking for [__] I go dude it's
kind of kind of
[__] change your ways that that
reminds me of the the text like a who is
an
addict I I remember I I remember one
time in LA at LAX I had a gram of coke
and a little bindle paper bindle I had
to fly it back to Jersey so I put it in
my sock they'll never think of that yeah
put it in my sock and when I got to
Jersey it was gone it was evaporated
from the heat of my feet swe it into
your foot it was I opened up F what
a
ripoff
yeah yeah dude okay so um now like like
I got some a couple questions okay um
the like I in my research I learned that
Skid Row was almost called skid
marks is that that true well I mean
people probably called us that anyways
well what they said they said that the
band was not named after the homeless
encampment in Los Angeles but rather you
guys were in a car and there was like a
near accident or something and like the
like a car went like and left skid marks
and and then someone in the like saw it
and said oh we'll call ourselves skid
marks that's not not true okay well
there we go that is not true we have we
have busted the m do you have uh bahaman
citizenship Bahamian Bahamian yes I you
do you have a passport I was no I have a
birth certificate I was born in Freeport
yeah born in Freeport and when I go
there which is rarely they make me go in
the returning resident line really so
that's kind of neat nice okay now the uh
Legend has it that skro got its big
opportunity from Bon Joy that's true but
Bon Joy got all the money well that's
[Laughter]
true so how did that work out for you I
mean uh no but then here's what here's
the honest to God truth that is that is
true that we signed a publishing deal
deal with him then in order for us to
sign it he would take us on his tour and
we were just a bunch of nobody's so
let's go on tour in in arenas I mean
that doesn't happen every day okay but
what I thought it sounded like is that
the publishing deal with Bon
jie was uh not a record deal so like
what you what you need is a record deal
what do you need a publishing deal for
to get on tour with bonjovi like like it
that's what it was because that just
sounds to me like some sug Knight
holding vanilla ice off the
balcony no I mean no nobody held me off
the balcony but but no all I can say
about it is that there was so many bands
at that time right there was so many
bands and the ones that made it were
very far and few between like making it
was like a unicorn and I understand what
you're saying but here's what we did we
had a big I quit the [__] band when
when we when I understood what we
signed I said I'm not doing this again
I'm not doing I'm not doing this again
so we had a big meeting with the um
lawyer Michael Guido who's now Jay-Z's
like right-hand business guy he was our
lawyer then and I said I'm quitting
unless we're redoing the whole thing
with Bon JY and I get 25% of everything
in band and there's five guys in the
band so that was kind of ballsy but they
said okay and then our next record so we
redid that we got out of that and then
our next record debuted at number one
there's really nothing better than
getting out of a bad deal and going on
to enjoy success Let me Give an example
like when I take a dump if I wipe my
butt with dry toilet paper then I'm
basically smearing poop around my anus
and my butt cheeks and as I walk through
the rest of my day I might develop a
rash some nasty chafing a generally
unclean unhappy happy and very
unsuccessful feeling but rather when I
use my bedet from hello tushi I am
pressure cleaning the poop off my
butthole so effectively that I walk
through the rest of my day feeling like
an absolute winner like Sebastian Bach
in that deal you know what I mean it's
just incredible it's my favorite sponsor
of the Wild Ride podcast I've always
said this it is my favorite product I've
ever been introd introduced to by this
podcast hello tushi I mean you sit down
on your toilet when you get done with
your sloppy dump you twist the dial and
you've got that
refreshing stream of water just power
cleaning just ah there's something so
satisfying about it I love it I love it
I love it and you're going to love it
too you'd be crazy not to it's the best
thing in the world so if you want to get
10% off your entire order you go to
hellotushy.com that's h l o
T
y.com and use the promo code steo again
for 10% off your entire order and it's
going to be the best move you ever made
your butthole is going to thank you day
after day like mine does my butthole is
a success because of hellotushy.com so
hellotushy.com use the promo code steo
and let's get back to
it on Billboard and it didn't sell quite
as many as the first but it did very
well that's the second record yeah slave
to the ground so you got in there and
and fixed that pretty quickly right well
I just said I'm not doing it again so I
was like I'm out so it's just so glaring
that you don't need a publishing deal
you need a record deal like a publishing
deal just kind of comes with writing the
music the only it literally is the same
thing as shight and Vanilla Ice except
just without the balcony or it's like uh
you know who's the old one like like
Otis reading [__] [__] like yeah yeah
well I mean I
mean you're right but but but all I can
say is that right looking back I have a
great life and I I get to play my music
I have a new record out coming very soon
my new song is on the radio and so like
I mean you gota you gotta you got a
break got to pay your dues and you have
if you have a break I mean looking back
maybe it was worth it maybe it was yeah
you know what maybe it was he put us in
front of all his fans yeah and we stole
a bunch of them how big were the shows
that he was doing at the time oh they
were that no more no like more yeah like
you know 1500 Arenas we did giant St
Stadium
75,000 wow we did you know was the New
Jersey tour we opened every show wow
okay I was just a baby though I was 19
wow 19 and 20 that was the first time
you started touring touring touring no
touring in arenas I toured before that
yeah yeah what's yeah what what's that
jump like what's the difference between
doing going from clubs to Arenas like is
there just a VIP feel to it
well I had a problem understanding
exactly what you're saying and I would
treat it still like I was in a club and
that ended getting me in trouble like
like how like I would jump in whoop some
[__] ass in the [__] Stadium
oh hell yeah yeah was like to the point
of where dude you're not in a club band
anymore like you know like now the
numbers are bigger I was just so young
like another mly crew thing like one you
know one time we got kicked off the Bon
Joy tour because I swore all the time on
stage but that was cuz you know like
going to see Vince Neil in chirano is
first thing he goes hey Toronto look at
all the [__] [__] here tonight and
here my buddy's go wow look at all the
[__] man this is [__] great we
thought it was hilarious like that he
would be talking like
that it wasn't like a m it wasn't a mean
putting down it was just funny to me and
my friend we thought it was funny also D
Snider was the way he would choose some
out if they weren't getting into it or
whatever it was just to me it was like
comedy and funny and like you better get
off your [__] ass and rock are you
buddies with d SN yeah I love D I love
him he's funny we just had him on yeah
we just had him on really a funny guy
man he's really funny he's really smart
he's really he's really you know like
he's he's humble yeah you know like the
way that he describes like just having
been like it's such an egomaniac so out
of control so impossible to deal with
and how like that just bit him in the
ass and and forced him into humility
like it's inspiring to talk to him it is
inspiring and he's in such amazing shape
for his
age and uh you know his wife susette
like that's a great team they've been
married for 41 years it's unbelievable
love love D yeah um now uh how um you
said that uh that your only thing is is
the
weed the like the and and of course the
booze just red wine nothing else okay no
shots no beer there was a point when
there was an issue there yeah I used to
drink all we used to in skid well I I
try to tell this like everywhere we went
like every like if we got in a car from
the airport
together there was a case of [__]
beer in in the car if we were go into an
interview there was a cooler full of of
beer everywhere we
went there was beer so [__] drink
that [__] like like why is it there like
so we were kind of always like a little
bit [__] up you know what was on what
was on your writer when you were well uh
I mean you know we Lov drinking beer
back then and Jack Daniels uh then we
discovered duall beer which was from
Holland and it was 15% stronger so we
put that on the riter and everybody was
[__] when we put that on there like
[__] this is some strong [__] man is
this Canadian no it's from
Holland so so uh so you just managed to
just reel it in H I just don't like I I
I I nice headline is that an actual
well I I drank every night of my life
you know what if I look at the years
hang on like if I look at like some
years
where like maybe
94 or 93 to like what's 25 plus
94 20
2019 I might I I I might I might have
had a little bit I I like it at night
you know but I'll tell you this I didn't
drink anything last night nothing
nothing all right did you have a did you
have trouble like slowing down from
drinking all that this is an old
cliche but this is the God's honest
truth learning to go to sleep on a tour
bus for me and many of my friends
involves having a couple of [__]
drinks for sure I'm just being honest so
so if I've spent all my life on a
[__] tour
bus that's not a crazy headline I mean
I'm just saying I can't I I find it
tough I think the secret is
to fall asleep before it starts driving
man I don't I can't sleep on the tour
bus and like my problem is I'll eat a
bunch of melatonin and then I get
restless leg syndrome right so then I'm
just like oh [__] [__] that was a nice
somebody did you get that on film yeah
any true but I'll be in bed just like
and it's like 5: in the morning you know
and I'm like I'm [__] the next day
well my thing is is that you usually
roll into the next town about 9 in the
morning sometimes ear earlier sometimes
later so I'm not going to get in my bunk
at 3: or 4 if I'm [__] going to have
to get up in a couple hours my brain
just says why do that yeah
anyways another thing
too I quit drinking for like maybe a
year once and it was [__] complete
misery no I
was why
because I went to LA and uh a lot of
people there were sober and [__] and it
was like a lot of people look down on
drinking at this time like what a loser
you're having a [__] I was like I'm
not a loser you know like it's like I
better I better I better put this [__]
down and see what that's like and all of
a sudden I got high blood pressure and I
went to the doctor you know physical and
I and he goes what are you doing I go
what do you mean he goes well you have
like high blood pressure I and I never
did in my whole life and I go he goes
what are you doing I go well I quit
drinking and he goes he goes he goes
what what do you mean he goes what did
you drink and I'd go well I'd go to like
the best steakhouse in
you know five star [__]
rainow Spearmint Rhino no more more like
in town here the Golden
Steer
uh not dantas they got a [__] hell
the the the brass Brass Rail The Brass
Rail the ti bar zanbar yeah great
chicken picata are you from Toronto too
no okay but so so um my daughter said
what did did you drink and I'd go well
I'd go to the best steakhouse in town
with my girl and we would order a filet
and Y and have like bottle of incredible
red wine and and and he
go yeah and he goes what do you do now
and I go well I I will never do that I
go I take ambian to go to sleep he goes
what the [__] he goes what I go well I
can't
sleep I'm too hyper and [__] he goes he
goes oh my God
he goes throw that [__] into garbage he
goes Sebastian do you know at the end of
the day when you want to chill out after
you've been rocking all day or whatever
it is and your body says okay man let's
have that glass of wine let's [__]
tone it down man and then you take it
away your body's going where is that and
he goes you're much better off
healthwise never taking those sleeping
pills ever again and how having a glass
of wine at night time before you go to
sleep and smoking your weed he goes
throw that [__] out and I go what this
my doctor I go are you sure this your
Vegas doctor
no a good he's a good [__]
doctor yeah I I go I go come on man and
at this time at this point I was like a
I thought I couldn't sleep without them
pills right so I go I go okay can you
just write me one more prescription for
those cuz I I just want to go to sleep
he goes and he look pissed off he
goes all right he [__] writes it to
me and I get and I go to the pharmacy
and I go here's my prescription they
bring it back to me in the Bott bottle
has one pill it I shake it up and I go
hey this is [__] I go there's only
one [__] P you go this is what your
doctor I go what a
prick sounds like old Sebastian Bach
would have been a lot happier if that
doctor wrote a prescription for an
entire month's Supply and I'm happy to
inform you that there is a situation
where you can get an entire month's
supply of one of my favorite things in
the world it's called a blue chw tablet
which has the same active ingredient as
both Viagra and Calis except it's
delicious chewable and only costs a
fraction of the price but check this out
and this is awesome because these things
make it really fun to get into bed with
your old lady um you can get an entire
month's supply of blue Chu tablets
completely for free if you go to
blue.com consult with the medical
provider online very quick and not a
prick like Sebastian box doctor and then
you use the promo code steo and you get
an entire month's supply of blue tablets
completely for free all you pay is five
bucks for shipping and it's that simple
dude epic so to get this entire month
supply again you go to bluechew.com and
use the promo code steo and then enjoy
your blueo tablets and have a lot of fun
in the sack like I do now let's get back
to
it just
[__] like what the [__]
one pill Dr feel good so the next night
I started back on the wine and to make a
long story even longer the next checkup
I went to my blood pressure is perfect
thank you very much all right my heart
my blood all that [__] yeah I have high
blood pressure and it's scary my doctor
told me to have some red wine at the end
of the day and now I don't have it so
I'm telling
you I've been so
that's probably why my blood pressure is
so high I hate to say it
but I'm a bad influenc no that's okay
okay like okay you went to grade school
with prince Andrew true he was the year
before me but I was the same school yes
Lakefield College school prince Andrew
came you were very young then yeah but
it was like
1978 and he went to uh School at
Lakefield College school outside of
Peterboro and I went to that exact same
school the very next year after he was
gone and I skipped the eighth grade at
that school which is pretty
crazy because you were smart yeah I was
well as we said I was born in the
Bahamas and my dad taught art at the
school Mary Star of the Sea School in
Freeport Bahamas and my parents didn't
really have money
and I was like three and so my dad said
[__] it and he put me in his class like
like he was like babysitting me and
teaching so so I did kindergarten in the
Bahamas when I was three then we moved
to
Canada and I did it again when I was
five so I was a little [__] bastard
at that point you knew I had
kindergarten down I was like bossing
body around did you graduate high school
like at 16 I didn't graduate high school
I left at in the 11th grade cuz I was
into band called kid Wicked in Toronto
we played the Gas Works and Larry's
Hideway and you had like the biggest
hair it was like spiked and dark huh
like yeah I loved all that did you ever
go back to get your GED no no his doctor
wouldn't let him
yeah so so uh so prince Andrew made an
unfavorable impression on you well no I
you
know I used to say a bunch of [__] in
magazines like I used to do 10
interviews a day so I'd think up funny
stuff and I pretended that I you know
knew him I never I never knew all right
well there we go we've put that to B but
I did go to that we both went to the
same school I didn't know Jeffrey
Epstein either I'll have you [__]
I wasn't in on that [__] you can [__]
Google that he went down that road I did
not I was hanging with Jimmy
Kimmel I wasn't on that [__] team
[__] man
um the uh your dad was an an artist he
he drew the album cover for Slave to the
Grind that's right yeah and he had a art
art gallery in Peterboro called Art
Space and he used to show in Toronto all
the time at like Nancy Pool Gallery and
um Gard gallery or like all the
Yorkville all that art community and
when I was in school yeah my God you're
looking this [__] up yeah I'm not making
it up um Nancy yeah that's it with the e
um gosh she's going to be like I'm in
Sebastian's interview that's
weird um so I'd be in school Queen Mary
school Peter Boro
Ontario and uh over the loudspeaker
would say Sebastian please come to the
principal's office I go [__] what did I
do now right and I would get down there
my dad would be there and go hey you
because you're I'm taking you out of
school today I go right on and it would
be to to help him hang his show like I
would be like his roie and but I would
be so excited we'd drive a truck to
Toronto I'd get and help him lift all
the paintings out of the truck and hang
them up and then every time I did that
he would take me to buy comic books
after I was done and and that was back
like when they were like a quarter MH
and I could get four for a buck and that
was the most incredible feeling I would
I loved I loved Comics cuz I actually
lived in C do you know where that is I
don't it's right near Mimi where Neil
Young grew up and it was like we only
had like three channels black and white
channels and then we moved to Peterboro
but when I lived in Cavin I lived in the
comic books I lived inside those like
the Hulk the Hulk was my favorite
Spider-Man Powerman Ghost Rider and I
collected them cuz I didn't watch TV
that much did you save any of those I
have them [__] I have I have the
first appearance of Spider-Man it's
worth like a quar million dollars it's
not in perfect condition but still you
do you yes I [__] do that's you ever
take it the Pawn Stars down the street
no but I that would that wouldn't be the
place to go I where would you go you'd
take it to an auction or something or
well they have these grading things
called C something CG and that if you
get them graded and put it they call it
slabbing into the stei is all about he
into that he's all about the
Collectibles slabbing he's got a way
like he's got his own like business for
grading you should link him up and
[__] I'm into it get a finder fee
yeah so's also is Glenn D Danzig he's
really into that big time man Glenn Dan
you your buddies with Glenn I am and
it's weird but I always tell this to
people
like you hear the way I talk you could
tell that I'm a metal singer just
because I talk high it's raspy like
Steve Tyler he you could tell he [__]
whales right just the way he talks I you
know you can hear that he's been
screaming that's just the way it is
Vince Neil he's like hey man he's like
hey dude what what the [__]
man that's Vince well [__] you shout
outed the
devil so but so Glen daning the way he
sings is like mother yeah tell your
children not to walk away so I was like
he must talk really low but guess what
man when I met him he was like Hey
Sebastian wait a minute I what you're
Glen dancing and he talks like I talk he
talks in a high pitched hey how's it
going hey man and I was like this is so
[__] up cuz his voice doesn't his
singing voice is like baritone but yeah
he did didn't he just do a like a a
dinner with Danzig in LA and he sang
Elvis songs I love and you know what I
me dude if you listen to Legacy
brutality it's like an Elvis
impersonator album so I don't understand
how he talks so high but he does and
it's crazy and what also trips me about
uh Glenn Danzig is his age man he's like
he's like [__] 75 or some [__] like
really how old were you when you first
realized that you could sing well I was
in the church choir when I was a like
eight no [__] no [__] like
78 he's 68 how old's uh Iggy
Pop 76 I mean he's shirtless and looking
can fit I know right it's amazing are
you shirtless when you go out there uh
not today not
today maybe a couple weeks I don't
know why'd you choose uh Vegas to live
out here well there's a couple reasons
um during the pandemic the doctors are
great out
here during I lived in Thousand Oaks for
like 3 years and then before that Studio
City yeah we got evacuated to two years
out of three in Thousand Oaks for fires
fires that the the big big coming right
coming right near our house and I'm like
[__] this like I mean one of the hardest
gigs I ever had to do I was in Orlando
Florida and my house was getting
evacuated while I was playing that night
and my wife's like we're evacuated and
my kids are like what do we take and
[__] and I had to go on stage and go hey
like like and I and I like my brain was
like dude your [__] house is going to
burn down like how can I go out and rock
yeah but I just went out there and I
said to the crowd listen man my house
might burn down during the Show
everybody's like
where 20 bucks [__] so you
better sing [__] yeah nobody cares no
but I said I
I right on well it's time for the show
to
start let's go we are the youth gone
wild man let's [__]
go and I'm like going up there
like you're like I just don't have
insurance and everybody's like
yeah actually what's crazy is that my
house in Jersey that I lost in Hurricane
Irene that happened during a concert
that I was opening for Twisted Sister in
[__] Colorado or something I come off
stage and like everybody's like hey man
and my house flooded and like I lost my
home during that concert so that would
that would have been the second time how
you had there it flooded I was playing
on stage in like Idaho or something it
was God's maack Sebastian Bach and
opening for Twisted Sister and when I
came off there was a Hur hurricane in
Jersey hurricane Irene if you want to
Google that long ago Hurricane Irene
Sebastian boach they want to see some
[__] depressing [__] did it take your
house away or just flooded the [__]
watch
this the crowd's cheering as your
[__] house hey man Sebastian B loses
home to Hurricane I well they have worse
pictures than that go go back to the
images cuz it shows my house like
[__] underwater and [__] there it is
there's my house underwater there it is
right there well that's different that's
me and the pandemic there it is right
there and like you're so you you have to
move out right yes do you have do you
get insurance for that or do you the
government FEMA yeah look at that that's
my [__] house underwater right there
um God I hate looking at that um how
long were you there for 19 years
man did you have like on the wall you
want to hear it's crazy dude okay you
see the water it's like up at my garage
there uh they sent the cops sent
divers into my basement to swim around
to look for dead bodies the whole
basement was under it was
underwater what about your plaques so
then I moov to California and I get
evacuated for the fire it's [__]
great I moved from the flood to the fire
yeah now and
now you got to go move to Tennessee for
the tornado the tornado well you know
what's weird about Vegas it's like hot
as hell in the summer but there's
nothing to burn cuz it's just like a
bunch of rocks and dirt yeah what is the
natural disaster here just well your
tires might melt in your car or
something that's it I think that uh like
water shortage would be concern yeah
yeah and it's crazy now that like
California is not even like doing
anything for fire
Insurance you can't
yeah what's the story with the fire
insurance with the I mean the Fair Act
plan or something it's like insurance
companies are just generally leaving
California and Florida as well I read
right so I think the two best places to
move would be Vegas or Ohio I think is
rated the best for climate change to
have the least issues really yeah but
then you got to live in
Ohio yeah um how do you feel about
cryptocurrency I don't know
man I met some guys some guys that hired
me to do a gig and they showed me on
their phone they had like 100 Grand and
[__] and my buddy Matt sorum showed me
on his phone he had like 300 Grand or F
I mean so I have like 200 bucks on there
yeah just to see what what happens to it
but you I don't really I don't really
can you really spend it anywhere oh yeah
yeah yeah you can certainly are you guys
into it I've been super resistant to it
until last night I had dinner with an
old dear friend of mine who I used to
call Billow I still call him Billow and
uh and and he and he finally convinced
me he's also um dying for me to text him
a photo of you and I together he's
losing he's losing his mind over how
awesome he thinks you are no problem my
wife made you guys snack and [__] how
long you been married uh I've been eight
years eight years yeah and you got kids
yeah how many kids we have uh five
between both of us wow can I ask you a
favor uhhuh our buddy Vinnie is getting
married tomorrow what tomorrow tomorrow
yeah you got any advice for him on a on
a beautiful marriage how long have you
known her almost a year okay and how old
are you
36 I'd say do it she's 22 she's 24 or 24
yeah almost a year that could be wor
I've known her since March March of last
year ah the only thing I would say is
that I got married way too young the
first time and I had no clue no [__]
clue that when like you left your chick
you still had
to I thought I thought you guys aren
together [__] later nobody even told
me that ever yeah nobody [__] told me
that going on tour still dealing okay I
met a chick when I was
15 and I'm
55 and I'm still giving her [__]
money man is that fair really look 15
years
old
55 when does it [__] end like is like
that's my whole life like child support
or alimony I I don't want to get just
just yeah
money 40 years like what is that enough
for is it what like how long does it go
like I mean like holy [__] that is
brutal a prison sentence and if somebody
says what would you say like holy [__]
dude if she's 24 and you're 37 and she
wants to break up with you like a year
from now oh my God that's not that's not
good at all why is it not good because
it's money but that's like ta I don't
understand taxes either I don't I don't
I don't really deal with that yeah yeah
I just paid my first taxes for the first
time ever last year I I don't understand
it it's
like that's why you moved to Nevada you
don't have to pay state tax that's
that's a very good thing like I just did
the mass singer the show right ah cool
it was really cool and they paid me a
[__] shitload of money but guess what
you get half they they mailed most of it
to the [__] tax guy go what the [__]
I know and I'm go since they go well
that's the way it I go since when is it
65% like
what I thought it was like 20% right but
I don't know I don't know then my
account says well if you make more they
take more I what do you mean what kind
of [__] is that
when do I get to [__] keep some
[__] holy [__] you give half here you go
my wife you get this you get this what
do I get [__] yeah yeah [__] what
other kind of cool Collectibles do you
have besides comic books good
change that's [__] right um you got
any other cool colle I collect kiss
stuff cars wow I collect I collect uh
kiss memorabilia and I and I collect
vinyl I really collect vinyl not all
vinyl Sebastian is such a fan of Kiss
yeah I am that it actually caused
skidrow to break up well that I
mean because in a way in a way because
there was an opportunity for skid R to
open for kiss on a kiss reunion tour in
1996 yes and says I'm a [__] huge
kiss fan he booked it then his band
Maids found out that they were booked
Skid Row was Butch to open for kiss and
they had they took on bridge with that
they said Skid Row is way too big of a
band to be an opening act no no no
that's that's that's not what happened
all right let's get the truth uh what
happened is the Bas player had a side
project a punk band that he got together
with the road crew guys from skid row
and they were busy and he couldn't do
the gig because he had because of the
side project and I and I got very angry
and I called the guitar player let him
know what I
thought voice he didn't pick up so I
just went you [__]
[__] and I just let him know it
was a very what I thought of them not
letting me play with kiss at the reunion
tour of of kiss in Jersey at the metal
lands Arena [__] and that was the last
draw and if you ask the base player of
them they they go that was there was a
lot of [__] leading up to that but that
was the very last so it was Kiss well
Dave said when cuz he goes my whole
family heard that [__] message he
goes that came out of the [__]
speaker and my whole family there was
Christmas because it was New Year's Eve
I was like that bridge too far I'm
coming over there right [__]
now [__] yeah answering machines when
the whole family can listen it's like he
goes that was it I feel like in the 80s
like rockers just calling each other
like what's up [__] like just a
whole mixtape of like 80s answering
machine from rocker to rocker would be
awesome I got kicked out of a Kiss
concert during thatan tour you did yeah
for what for what for fire breathing in
the STS
I was just like dude I know James
Simmons is big into fire breathing and
I'm like dude I'm ready and I'm I'm just
like in The Stance and I just I just
popped one off oh my Lord huge Fireball
and they're like you're out of here oh
my gosh were you I'm like you know what
like uh you got me yeah you got me and
everybody knows I blew a bigger
Fireball then Jean Simmons well also
Jean Sim has never jumped out of a plane
and and and
Cave me that's pretty tough to beat
right there I don't know how you can
compartmentalize when you're jumping out
of a plane thank you shoot a big load
like yeah I couldn't do that I got to be
like you know kind of well than thank
you for knowing that man thank you for
knowing
that D I love it um jar so so tell us
about your new music I have a new song
it's called what do I got to lose news
and it's co-written with uh Miles
Kennedy and I am pleased to say that it
was the number one most added song on
active Rock uh a couple weeks ago in the
United States and I've been doing this
for almost 40 years and for the radio
stations in America to play my new [__]
that means so much to me that's really
incredible to me like I don't just have
to play the old song right like I can
throw this [__] in there now that's
awesome I love that I love that when you
make a song you want to go on the radio
versus Spotify and YouTube right like
the radio still old I'm old school
Spotify don't pay [__]
yeah everybody knows that I just there's
no feeling like the radi like getting in
your car putting radio on and hearing
yourself like that's that never gets old
that's cool and I gotta I actually got
to give a shout out to Sirius XM because
I think that is really good for my
career like guys like me every car that
you buy comes installed with siries XM
right then you have the option after two
weeks or whatever to get but for those
two
weeks like every every five songs on
Channel 39 is me like I'm like Michael
McDonald of Yacht Rock like every every
third song I can say you will he he us
with freedom Shining Light on like and I
go every three songs you're going to
hear Michael McDonald sing and you can
time it and so he has that channel and I
got Channel 39 ha Nation what are they
referencing I don't I don't even know
what they call it I want to be known
from my oh are you uh at all involved in
the um the docu series nothing but a
good time no God damn it because our
jackass director Jeff Tain is helming
the uh adaptation of the book nothing
but a good time which is all about 80s
hair metal right and uh and he's making
it for Paramount plus where it will
probably also like live on linear for
VH1 or MTV or you know whatever but uh
but yeah that pisses me off that you're
not a part of that well I read that book
and I I didn't like it or you didn't no
what what was your issue did you read it
I did not well you come on he's reading
books you can read it and then and then
ask me all right click on that Amazon
one nothing but a good time that's the
uncensored
history wow and you you didn't like this
one no but were they unfair to you I I'm
just going to say if you read
it
then you could ask me about
it all right because I actually read it
okay fair enough um a lot of people have
asked me about this and then I say did
you read it and every one of them says
no and I go well don't [__] ask me
about it unless you read it okay fair
enough I uh was interviewed by Jeff Tain
for the the show uhhuh and um what if
uh something or other is that out it's
not out it's not out yet but I think
they that's been out for Years the book
has been
out main thing yeah yeah they uh they've
delivered it I don't believe it's out
yet and um Brett Michaels uh became good
buddies with uh shaa who's Train's sort
of uh partner in production are you
buddies with Brett Michaels yes yeah
yeah he's cool he's a hardworking guy
God he's great I opened up a poison tour
and
um he would say at the end of the poison
show hey
man we're doing another show in an hour
from now at [__] Jimmy's
barbecue down the street you're all
invited he would I'd be exhausted right
after playing for 45 minutes he would do
a full poison show and then book a solo
Brett Michaels show that night like
right down the street and he' go come on
down and I go down there and he would be
signing t-shirts for chicks for [__]
till 3: in the morning I'd be like and
he's like hey how you doing how you
doing I go this [__] has a lot
of energy yeah he's a very hardworking
guy that's Epic Man um now you said that
your your new song The Singles getting
radio AirPlay but presumably part of an
album it is yeah and what's the name of
the album [__] I don't know if I could
say that right they have it all
staggered okay God so the singles come
out the album's not out yet that's right
that's right but the next song we're
doing is uh a song I wrote with John
five from mle crew oh wow and he plays
Incredible on it um uh and we're get
getting ready to do that video I would
love for you to be in a video dude being
some crazy [__] liting your nuts on fire
or something I'm I'm into it yeah we're
not too far from Vegas okay that would
be great Craig gas is in the first one
press play D I love Craig G can you
press play there and I would like you to
be dud I'm I'm down d a video dude I'm
super down bro you're like I don't say
this very often but like you're one of
my favorite new people are you kidding
me this has been a hoot dude we've been
cracking up the entire time oh my Lord
you like we we we fall in love with some
guests but not all the time man you're
funnier than D Snider
what yeah I mean we've laughed pretty
damn hard this whole time dude it's been
a it's been a joy um are do do you
social media and stuff I do but as I get
older uh it becomes like a chore to me
it's like CU there's so many platforms
like I got to post this on Instagram and
then share it to Facebook and then share
that to Twitter and then you can't
forget about threads and then you got
post on Tik Tok and then you I don't
have [__] time to do that yeah you
know yeah it's a it just becomes like a
a job yeah it is a job but it's like
kind of
it I love putting my video up and having
it available so we can watch it anywhere
that's great you know it's good for
getting a word out on [__] but it can
consume your [__] life if you let it
if you just sit there all day mhm
consume your life so true but it's just
Sebastian Bach on Instagram same across
all the platforms all right well I'm
going to jump on that dude I'm gonna
follow you well I'm gonna tell my people
that you want to be in a video dude
let's do it oh my God that is killer bro
yeah dude that's exciting what's the
next video well there's one come coming
called freedom and we're talking to Dane
Cook about that one okay Dane's my buddy
yeah
but he's pretty busy but um and then
there's one called wait I can't I don't
know if I can be say this but anyways
I'm GNA get your digits you got it we'll
line it up cuz I got a great director
and we're you know they're got good
budgets and cool man it's a real video
dude I love it man sick so sick they
don't they don't shoot a lot of videos
these days you know so yeah well dud
we'll do it man I'm in okay are you guys
driving back to LA right now no no no
you stay in Vegas he's getting married
tomorrow in Vegas yeah in Vegas what are
you doing tonight tonight I got date
night with my lady not and she in Vegas
she's in Vegas yeah nice she's losing
her mind over how like how she would
love to meet uh I mean my wife would
love to meet your wife well like uh I I
will run it by my lady we we'll see what
happens can you guys come in now and say
are we done we're done
okay now how is that for a wild ride huh
did I tell you
amazing um so let me check in with my
street team um I'm here on this uh
impractical Joker's cruise I've been uh
meeting people who have identified
themselves as street team I love that we
don't even make a big deal out of like
what that is anymore you either know or
you don't know if you're street team you
know and if you're street team I love
you we're having a blast show the room
for the people who have video component
we got Scott Randolph we got Dan Daniel
Maya Paul brisy Isaac Patterson and turn
it on yourself old skinny Vinnie The
Newlywed yeah dude it's uh just the boys
in the middle of the ocean having a
blast and uh for this cruise I put
together a uh new show man like I had to
like that was what you know I have to do
a show on stage for an hour and I'm like
dude my uh my bucket list tour is over
my next tour I haven't put the show
together like I don't have a show
and uh and it was like man I just I just
got to it I sat down and huge props to
the gorgeous Paul brisy over there who
helped me develop what uh what we
brought to the stage just a blistering
like obscene and and frankly shameful
journey through uh the most awful and
and inappropriate things in the whole
history of of Jackass Wild Boys steo
like uh basically the worst of the worst
and um I I mixed it all together into uh
kind of a a you know my my plans and my
progress for uh my next tour so it'll
gradually morph into my next tour and
I'm just excited about it and that's why
I told you dude if you're on this Cruise
man [__] shout out let's go and if
you're not on this cruise I love you
anyway and